is the president telling us the truth
that the rising gas prices are not his
fault
no it's baloney the gas prices are up 61
since the time that he took office part
of it is because of the overhang of the
pandemic but the other part of it is is
the anti-energy
actions that this administration has
taken
putting a halt on new leasing
taking anwar off the table uh you know
saying they're going to
have new taxes and regulations and not
only that but this whole thing is a
kabuki
it is a fake uh action to try and look
like they're doing something about it
think about this 50 million barrels now
in reality it's 32 million barrels
because 18 million barrels were already
authorized
by congress to be sold in order to gain
revenue for the government to pay for
all these for for part of the spending
program so it's only 32 million barrels
now why is that important because
america uses 19 million barrels of oil a
day so they've just between the 32
million that the administration is
actually used
doing and the 18 million that congress
already told them to sell to make money
that's 2.6 days worth of energy
for the united states oil and gas now
look at this we're also doing this they
say in cooperation with countries around
the world china india japan south korea
and the united kingdom well the only
country out of this that produces much
oil and gas is china
india doesn't it produces a million
barrels a day japan
123 000 barrels a day south korea
negligible the united kingdom nature
will
the people have got the oil opec have
already told the u.s government to take
a hike they're going to increase the
amount of production modestly
not a lot and they've already told the
administration we're not going to help
you solve your problem and and so now we
announce we're cooperating with people
who don't have oil and gas yeah so carl
this energy release is going to give us
2.6 days of energy for america that's
unbelievable but mick i want to get
reaction to this because the energy
secretary granholm
she made a statement and didn't know how
much oil the u.s consumes take a look
there are various figures about this i'm
curious if you know how many barrels of
oil does the us consume per day i don't
have that number in front of me
mick you and i were both in politics
together i can't believe that she
wouldn't know the answer to that
question it's like a teacher not knowing
how many kids are in his class what do
you say to that
yeah it's that's the type of stuff that
gets you fired it just does it's the
type of thing that makes the president
look bad and again it's the one thing
you cannot do as a cabinet member is
make the president look bad it's an easy
number it took me 15 seconds to find out
what that means is they're not doing the
work necessary to prep at the energy
department for a press conference which
makes you wonder what they're doing with
their time and my guess is to carl's
point they're spending their time trying
to figure out how to make us produce
less keep in mind done to the trump
administration we were net exporters of
energy the price of gas sean it's pretty
simple you you you and i understand this
it's a it's supply and demand the more
supply the price goes up the more demand
the price goes up excuse me more supply
the price goes down we're in a situation
now where this administration is
limiting our own ability to get our oil
and natural gas to market and that is
driving the price up what people don't
want to talk about is the fact we don't
buy any oil from opec we really don't
most of our oil that we buy from
overseas comes from canada and to a
certain extent venezuela we don't buy it
from the mideast most of what we consume
here in the united states we make here
and when the with the bite
administration has changed their
policies it's had a direct impact on how
much you and i and everybody else is
paying at the pump and the secretary of
energy needs to know that or else she
needs to go so mick you and i saw this
firsthand we served in congress together
on the financial service committee and
all of these do good progressives who
care about the weather what they want to
see is energy prices go up so we'll make
a transition to greener energies and i
would i hear about this all the time
this is one of the biggest issues that i
hear when i'm around in wisconsin people
talk about gas prices carl quickly what
kind of impact does this have in
elections when people are angry about
kitchen table issues like gas prices
when they fill up their cars
well obviously it's a big reason why the
administration has such lousy marks on
the economy inflation and jobs and let
me tell you though there is good news
the international
energy agency says there a reprieve from
the price
rally could be on the horizon and what
does that reprieve from
when the u.s production rises next year
they hope so the answer is produce more
energy you have more energy the price
will go down answer simple
yeah i know it is simple gentlemen
listen i want to thank you guys for both
joining me tonight and for your insights
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else